but here he is we have five yeah no Kara
wanna with Maurice Ashley and he is our
new US Champion the champ is here
Fabiana Caruana closing it out with the
wind first of all Bobby congratulations
on being the new US Champion what does
it mean to you to be the champion of
your country this was one of the most
important tournaments I mean I and of
course the candidates was also extremely
important for me but I would say this
storm it was was massively important
that and I I really came in wanting to
win the title so yeah it's um I not sure
if it's my biggest achievement to date
but probably one of the one of the wins
I'm most satisfied with winning a
tournament with such illustrious
opposition you had tough players you had
to defeat one of your main rivals Hikaru
Nakamura
he also played some really nice games
was it satisfying from a creative point
of view yeah I think overall I played
pretty good chess there was one weak
moment yesterday against Kamsky but I
think in a tournament it's it's pretty
much expected that you're going to have
one weak moment at least so yeah I think
overall my play was quite good you won
two with black as well of four with
white with black
what was the thoughts about today's game
in particular well I didn't want to take
too many risks because I mean as it
turns out probably draw would have been
enough I think Wesley so is not making
any progress in this game but I also I
mean of course Wesley and Hikaru could
can win against anyone and okay I mean
they had a tough situation they were
both playing black but I thought that I
should at least play for win and and try
to try to not leave my faith in my
opponents hands there was a tricky
position in your game that happened when
you took on c3 did you see that he had
this rookie one visual reference aquifer
yeah that's why I spent so much time
because
yeah if I don't take on c3 let's say I
take on e3 Queen takes and a play queen
c6 now I think a strong move his be 394
Queen c1 leads nowhere so at some point
I'm going to have to trade pawns and
then the bishop on c4 was really strong
just cemented there with my problem a
sixes is weak and he has a C file to
potentially attack my C pawn so this I
really didn't like so I spent a lot of
time calculating he takes c3 or Goethe
woman is the most testing of clean c6
Bishop f7 King f7 Queen c4 Queen e6
Queen c5 and here I saw a few ways in
which I thought I should be able to hold
the position without big problems and I
was also I mean I didn't really want to
go for this but objectively my position
slightly worse so I don't think I had
anything better and here I saw some I
worked d-141 King g8 was decent also I
thought that IBC takes me to is the
rookie won't well I mean I'll probably
win the e pawn maybe I'll end up down a
poem but would obstacle a bishops and
his King is a bit weak I would actually
say his King after I take money for and
have the light-square bishop down the
diagonal his King is weaker than mine so
I wasn't I didn't really feel like I was
in much danger oh he should probably
take home c7 because this is just good
for Block C Queen c7 and rook f7 and
then I can go Mitch somebody's extremely
safe his King seems less safe so okay so
you assess this position when you went
for this line I mean the other way it's
just too easy for him his placed too
easy and at least here he'll have to
calculate um make some difficult moves I
don't know if he saw this and rejected
it or if you just didn't see it Wow
great assessment thanks for clearing
that up with us
Wesley Wesley is now drawn so in the
distance are your competitors in this
competition did you think it would
you would win by what it turns out is it
a football you think you've even buy a
full point in this field I can't say I
expected it I mean I can't even say
expect it to win but I think in terms of
the quality of play probably I deserve
deserve the result I mean plus 6 and I
wasn't really in danger in any game as
well if you look at the games of other
players I mean they played well but they
were endangering some games and like
Wesley was losing in the second round I
mean I think my play was probably most
consistent so the result doesn't seem to
it seems pretty logical to me you had a
very near miss in Moscow does this wind
make up for it yeah it so I'm really
happy with this it's uh it's probably
the strongest use championship in
history I mean if this competition was
really tough Wesley and Andy Karawang
are extremely dangerous opponents and
and maybe with some luck on their side
they could have scored +6 but yeah but I
mean this is in terms of quality of play
and and the result of winning the US
Championship it's one of my most
satisfying wins there are other
tournaments that come in the near future
the Olympic team Olympia we're gonna
have a very strong team you knock Wesley
so it looks like Ray Robson is on the
team as well
what do you fashion as your chances to
winning a maybe a gold medal at the
tournament we have our chances I
wouldn't say they're necessarily better
than other top teams but we have our
good chances if if all the players come
together so you're committed to playing
in that tournament
of course what about next year's
championship you've won one the number
of players in that world two players in
this tournament who won four more than
for not winning for complimenting five
would you be defending your title next
year I'm exhausted right now I don't
wanna think about well congratulations
on your victory in your very first
championship
we appreciate your play in your time
with us and thanks for giving us so many
entertaining games
Fabiano Khurana the 2016 us
Chess Champion I'm sure it's got a nice
ring to it first place $50,000 richer
well deserved that's right thanks for
clean back and everybody was talking
about how much they enjoyed this
championship and of course